our scripture of the day proverbs 19 1
better is a poor person who walks in his
integrity than one who is crooked in
speech and is a fool CS Lewis said
education without values as useful as it
is seems rather to make a man more
clever a more clever devil yeah money
without values does that to values give
you the skeletal structure in your
character to carry knowledge or money or
power or even some fame because it's all
kind of dangerous if it's by if it's
placed on somebody that's value that has
no values then you get you get train
wrecks you get dumpster fires I mean you
get all kinds of problems it's just on
you have to have values and you go this
is what this is Who I am and you know
the thing about that is some people have
trouble making decisions you have
trouble making decisions I used to have
trouble making decisions a lot and then
I firmly set out loud and wrote down
several things that are non negotiables
in my life meaning my values and we've
done that here at the company as well we
have 15 actually 14 core values on the
wall and those are who we are they're
not just things we put on a brochure
they're not things it is who we are I
was talking about one of them this
morning in staff meeting as a matter of
fact and it tells us who we are and so
what that means is a lot of our
decisions are already made now we don't
always like having to follow through
because it involves conflict that
involves pain and involves you know
having to face people and face our fears
and all that kind of stuff but but when
you have your value system in place then
it automatically gives you your answer
in a lot of cases not all the time but a
lot of cases it just goes you know
because it's non-negotiable I don't do
that an example is simple one in my
personal life is here this will come to
a shock to all of you not have you've
ever heard me say this before I don't
borrow money so a lot of my decisions
are made because if I don't have the
money I can't buy it it's a pretty
simple formula isn't it I can't afford
that I can and it doesn't matter how
rich you get there's something you can't
afford I mean I was with a friend of
mine the other day as a new Gulfstream
unbelievable fifty-two million dollar
aircraft I can't afford one of those I
can't afford it it's very nice though
I'll tell you summer Sadie's in the air
man it's a Bentley in the air it's
unbelievable
but I can't afford that thing I can't I
can't afford it and he's only the money
for it and so even if I wanted it I
don't really want it I was just very
nice but I mean it's pretty incredible
but I just can't afford it the decision
is already made
because I already decided the other part
of the decision which is I don't borrow
money now I could probably afford the
payments on it actually if I was stupid
enough to borrow money on a fifty two
million dollar aircraft but that would
be like that's like fifty two million
worth of stupid right there hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]